e
Monday March 10th
2025 this is the New Hampshire House of
Representatives Municipal and County
government committee I am representative
Diane power and the committee has
convened today for the purpose of
executive sessions on 18
bills so at this point I would ask that
everybody be sure that your cell phones
are silenced and please join us in
reciting the Pledge of Allegiance led by
to the flag of the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
all thank you and before we begin this
morning as always I have just a few
morning announcements as I said the
committee of has convened this morning
at 9:30 for the purpose of um holding
executive sessions on 18 bills that we
previously had public hearings
on and as we approach the noon time hour
um what I'm going to say is I will um
poll the committee and ask the committee
based
on where where we are with regards to
executing this bills and we can decide
if we just want to continue and finish
up or would we prefer to take lunch and
in which case we would return after
bills
okay Madam chairman yes i' like to call
for Republican caucus yes um I'll allow
that how much
time approximately half an hour okay
okay so
that based on that clock clock over
there um we will come back in 30 minutes
10:05
e
okay so at this time the chair will open
the executive session on House Bill 200
relative to the procedure for overriding
Madam chair I'd like to offer an
amendment the chair recognizes
representative
kazinski like to amend House Bill 200
d573 is there a second Madam chair I'd
like to second that um representative
Murphy seconds that representative
kazinski would you like to speak to your
motion
yes this just
uh cleans up
the method to override local tax
cap okay is there any um discussion on
this amendment representative grund is
recognized yes I'd like some uh
clarification if I could Madam chair on
B School District shall place the the
warrant article for SAU budget the
beginning of the school district warrant
article not all school districts have a
separate SAU budget so is this requiring
a separate sa budget suddenly um thank
you for the question representative
grund I I I would all like to speak to
the amendment as well as to respond to
your inquiry so this amendment here it
it does two things so um with regards to
lines 14 and 16 on the bill the
amendment um cleans up some confusing
language
um in the bill as file regarding
multi-year warrant articles um which is
that language is is being
misinterpreted
um what's happening is that um bonds
interpreting that bonds are never
subject to the tax cap after the first
year so the amendment addresses that to
um to clarify that and to to your
inquiry on lines 21 through 20
um two of the bill with regards to
section B of the amendment um that
recognizes that there are multiple ways
to to um have an SAU budget warrant
article there is a statute and it's
um RSA
colon
9-b which is um enabling statute and
that allows for what is called the
alternate budget procedure and that's um
that's one way uh to to handle the SAU
Budget on the warrant and so that's
that's what the amendment clarifies
that can I follow up on that yes so when
it says but the school district shall
place the warrant article does that
indicates that the saus are going to
place no matter what which says they're
going to have to
separate and that's not the way many
enabling what that's referring to is
that if you do have a separate one
beginning and if you have a separate one
then that comes on the AL alternative
budget
procedure representative
Davis uh thank you madam chair first of
all I don't see that in the amendment
and second of all the amendment does say
shall it doesn't say may it says
shall I think that's tremendously
confusing for anyone attempting to put
forward an SAU budget that doesn't fit
with
the structure proposed in this
amendment but if if the SAU spending is
is in the operating budget for the
school you don't have an SAU separate
budget so it doesn't
apply
further
discussion representative
Colby um my main concern haven't been
addressed either in the bill or in the
amendment which is the stepping on voter
Authority um it makes it makes it more
difficult for an electorate to have
their voices heard um the bill also
offers no adoption procedure um instead
of mandating that all communities with a
tax cap use this method um instead of
respecting the will of the community at
large thank
you further
comments representing majority is
recognized thank you madam chair uh
chairwoman
um this provision of law of Statute was
amended last year and it went into
effect in October of
24 so now we have a bill to fix the am
fix the law from last year which has now
been amended again I have no faith that
what we have in front of us addresses
the issues which have only been in
effect since October of 24 furthermore
I'm not even sure we had a problem in
October of 24 if that's law that passed
so this to me is I I have no faith that
what we have in front of us is worthy of
passing further comments
wait mean to do so I I have a
comment with regard to the
bill a a bill was referenced from from
last year that addressed a totally
separate issue House Bill 200 is not a
housekeeping Bill House Bill 200
addresses the vote threshold by which a
local tax cap is
overridden changing it from a simple
majority to a
35ths
majority so it's completely different
and it it's it doesn't
relate to the bill that was the the
year the only the only similarity is
it's the same um
discussion representative grundt I feel
I just I just need to clarify on that
194c so A School District like Hollis
Brookline that separates out their sa
budget they vote on it separately so
that would be placed on the warrant
article before these other things as
indicated here a a school district like
mine we have
sau39 amher school district soan school
district Monon School District we do not
separate out our SAU budget it is part
of all of our budgets it's spread out by
number of students therefore I'm worried
about B now forcing school districts to
place the warrant article for the SAU
budget we don't separate it out and this
is not enabling and it's kind of does
not separate out the um
comments seeing none the motion before
accepting the amendment you'll vote Yes
if you're opposed um you will vote no
the clerk will call the
role Vice chairman McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk votes
yes representative France
yes representative Kosinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes Representative stavis
no representative Gilman
no Representative majori
no representative frock
no representative Colby
no Representative gerana
no representative Gerard
no Representative grund
yes Amendment 2025
d573 H to House Bill 200 is accept with
a vote of 10 to8 do I have a further
motion Madam chair representative Walker
is recognized for a motion I'd like to
uh pass the uh
hb200 approve
it your your motion is to approve is uh
to pass with amendment is that correct
correct is there a second to that motion
representative Dolan seconds that
discussion
seeing none the motion before us is
ought to pass with Amendment on House
Bill 200 if you're in favor of that
motion you will vote Yes if you are
opposed to the motion you will vote no
the clerk will call the
role Vice chairman
McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward yes
the clerk votes
yes representative France
yes representative Kosinski yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Walker yes Representative stavis
no representative Gilman
no Representative majori no
representative frock
no representative Colby no
representative Jana
no representative Gerard
no representative grunt
the committee recommendation on House
Bill 200 is ought to pass with
amendment that will go on the regular
calendar and I I will write the the
report Minority
you and with that the chair will close
at this time the chair will open the
executive session on House Bill
374 relative to clarifying references
under local tax cap and budget
laws do I have a motion Madam chair
representative Walker is recognized for
a motion I'd like to offer an amendment
[Music]
I'd like to second that representative
Murphy seconds that representative
Walker would you like to speak to your
motion uh plainly this is just a
housekeeping Bill clarifying some
terms and making the bill the base Bill
uh better if you want to clarify more
discussion oh representative majori
thank you m mam chairwoman
um the ability of an effective governing
body to manage The Prudent Affairs of
their Community depends on upon their
capacity to be responsive to the unique
quality in life and culture within their
Community when local officials make
decisions they are carrying out the
policy values set forth by the majority
of their residents policy values set
forth by the majority give the governing
body purpose and direction this is one
in a raft of bad bills that if passed
will undermine prudent management of
local affairs thwart the will of the
majority increase the influence of
special interest groups and local
government and create barriers to
repealing harmful errors in rules and
actions I am opposed to the amendment
comments I have a comment this bill is a
housekeeping
Bill we are not voting on whether
whether we like or
dislike local tax Caps or School
District budget caps it is a bill that
corrects
um references that were missing in
statute which is needed because these
missing
references need to be corrected in order
for the statute to function properly
and it also
um
clarifies definitions that need
clarification so again this is simply a
housekeeping bill and I I
support the amendment and the underlying
Bill to to that end representative
stavis is recognized thank you madam
chair um and with all due respect this
may be a housekeeping bill but there are
lots and lots lot of different ways of
housekeeping um and the bottom line for
me is that this is one of several bills
that undermine local control and local
control is what the New Hampshire
legislature has always been about not
extending the long arm of government
into the way municipalities conduct
their
seeing none the motion before us is to
2025-the
yes if you are opposed to the amendment
you will vote no the clerk will call the
role Vice chairman McDonald
yes representative Guthrie yes
representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes clerk votes
yes representative France
yes representative karasinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes Representative stavis
no representative Gilman
no representative majori
no representative frock
no representative Colby
no Representative gerana
no representative Gerard
no Representative grund
225-5787
is accepted with a vote of 10 to8 do I
have a further
motion like that make a motion we
PA representative Dolan motions ought to
pass with Amendment on House Bill 374 is
there a second yes I second that
representative fron seconds that
representative Dolan would you like to
speak to your
motion I would like to defer
to
sorry I'd like to defer my comment to
the to the chair as the prime sponsor
thank you representative Dolan I have no
further comments at this time as I did
speak to the amendment um um there's
nothing further to add representative
majori thank you madam chairwoman
housekeeping to me is is a minor
contextual change maybe word here and
there we have the original
bill was three p excuse me two pages the
amendment is an entire page that's much
more than
seeing none the motion before us is
ought to pass with Amendment on House
Bill 374 if you're in favor of the
motion you'll vote Yes if you are
opposed to the motion you will vote no
the clerk will call the
role Vice chair
McDonald
yes representative Guthrie yes
representative Dolan
yes representative Elward yes clerk
votes
yes representative France
yes representative Kosinski
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Walker
yes Representative stavis
no representative Gilman
no Representative majori
no representative frock
no representative Colby
no Representative gerana
no representative Gerard
no Representative grund
no Madam
chair
yes the motion passes with a vote of 10
to8 the committee recommendation on
House Bill 374 is ought to pass with
amendment I will write the majority
report Minority Report
author representative majority thank
you and with that the chair closes the
next the chair will open the executive
session on House Bill 138 local relative
to tax impact notation on warrant
motion representative France is
recognized for a motion I'll make a
motion of ought to pass for HB 138 local
is there a second Madam chair I would
like to second that representative
Murphy seconds that representative
motion well I just think this bill is a
good thing to put um to have a
requirement on a special warrant article
that does list the estimated tax impact
um for a
long-term um
multi-year
contract further discussion
representative stavis has
recognized thank you madam chair I think
the key word key word in representative
Fran's comment was
estimated
um if you're if you're implying a tax
impact for your voters and that impact
can only be an estimate based on
everything that we heard and all the
evidence that was presented to us in a
hearing about about Bond rates being
changeable over the years there is
simply no way that you can deliver truth
to the voters in in a bill such as this
tax impact is an estimate it's a guess
it's not what the impact is going to be
it's just a guess and no one can make an
informed choice on a
guess further comments
discussion representative um Gil is
recognized thank you madam chair um I am
opposed to this bill because first
because the Department of Revenue
Administration was not contacted and
they are the ones that work with the
towns to set the tax rate um
also as as fellow representative stavis
said um things vary we don't know what
our revenue is we don't know uh what our
uh property values are going to be and
their evaluations within the 5-year
period uh so these things would affect
these lease agreements
um at any
time thank you
further further comments um
representative grund is
recognized thank you madam chairwoman so
my concerns about when we talk about
estimates I'm going to give you an
example of the bonds which is what this
is really about when you do a when you
when you start working on a bond you're
working on it first of all the prior
year you get estimates from the Bond
Bank in October or November you have
public hearings December January
deliberative sessions February voting
March you don't sell the bonds until
later in the summer when that happen
your interest rate has changed think
about what's happened since October
until what might happen J June or even
now that is a huge estimate but yet
you've put this out there and you have
to educate your public um I'm very
concerned concerned about the estimates
on it um you know what happened to local
control if a town would like to have
this type of information included on
their Ballot or in their voter guides to
communicate to the public then that can
be done without this legislation
calculations that may be inaccurate due
to budgeting 8 months in advance changes
in valuations changes in interest rates
and terms when selling bonds and other
estimated concerns does not communicate
accurate information to taxpayers and
estimating a tax impact 5 years out is
going to be difficult to defend when
it's not the actual impact to two or
three years later thank you thank you
further comments representative Elward
is recognized thank you madam chairman I
actually have a question I can someone
refresh my memory as to whether or not
the Department of Revenue showed up in
bill my recollection representative
Elwood is that they did
not may I follow it sure
so if the Department of Revenue um did
not show up to oppose this
bill speaking to one of the rep's um
comments um I don't see why anyone would
not be in favor thank
you further comments discussion
representative Gilman is recognized
thank you madam chair uh in response to
representative alward's comment I did
not say Dr did not attend the hearing I
said they were not uh um asked to even
comment on the the bill itself they were
not uh consulted on the bill and whether
or not what kind of problems it would U
affect in
towns further discussion representative
McDonald is recognized thank you in
reference to uh Dr I
on when we have our deliberative
sessions we present the same information
and I don't recall anyone coming from Dr
in order to provide that information to
the the voters or Dr ever saying there's
an issue or problem with the way we
present uh this of the how much cents
per thousand thank
you further comments representative
Colby uh so we've heard uh posting
multi-year tax impacts um are borderline
irresponsible governing bodies being
mandated to provide inaccurate forecast
knowing full well their residents are
making financial decisions based on
falsehoods I feel the bill advocates for
fiary malpractice and SWS seeds of
distrust the state should not be
suggesting that local officials violate
their legal or ethical
obligations thank you thank you further
comments representative stavis is
recognized representative Colby just St
stated exactly what I was going to say
this is a
misrepresentation can be a
misrepresentation is by definition a
misrepresentation because it's an
estimate voters cannot decide in their
best interests based on an estimate and
where is their recourse by the way when
that estimate is wrong
further
comments seeing
none the motion before is is ought to
pass on House Bill 138 if local if you
are in favor of that motion you will
vote Yes if you are opposed to the
motion you will vote no clerk will call
the
role Vice chairman
McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk votes
yes representative France
yes representative kazinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes Representative stavis
no representative Gilman
no Representative majori
no representative frock
no representative Colby
no Representative gerana
no representative Gerard
no Representative grund
yes the motion passes with a vote of 10
to8 the committee recommendation on on
House Bill 138 local is ought to pass
that will go on the regular
calendar and for the majority
report representative France and
Minority Report will be representative
Colby thank you and with that the chair
closes the executive session on House
next the chair opens the executive
session on House Bill 284 FN requiring
tax impact statements on Municipal
warrant
articles Madame chairman Vice chairman
McDonald is recognized I'd like to offer
Amendment 2025
d571
H thank you is there a second Madam
chair I would like to second that
representative Murphy seconds that
representative McDonald would you like
to speak to your your motion yes I would
thank you uh this is very similar to the
uh previous uh bill that we just passed
and there's been a lot of questions
about estimate estimate estimate well if
you look at the
bill and the war could say if this war
anle passes there'll be an
estimated weight estimated estimated tax
impact of a certain amount per thousand
of the evaluation for year one and then
everything is estimated they're not
saying the town's not saying it's going
to be eight cents a thousand 10 cents a
thousand they giving you the best
ballpack figure of what exists currently
on that particular day when you
vote um again I I I think it's better to
be open have open government in
providing the taxpayers how much
everything is going to cost on their tax
rate uh unfortunately there are other
people that don't agree that agree with
that and I respect their opinion but I
think openness in government is better
than having uh no figures at all thank
discussion I'd like to make a couple of
comments um this amendment here before
us it cleans up statutory language in
the bill as it was
filed when the bill was was filed
unfortunately multi- toown
districts was not um accommodated for in
the bill language multi-year warrant
articles uh is is imported in
and also this amendment provides that on
an sb2 ballot that the total tax impact
um will be
noted further
comments representative Dolan thank you
madam chair I I just think it's worth
noting that several communities do this
quite well and they should be commended
for their openness and and disclosure
some communities however don't do a very
good job with this and this uh would put
a requirement on those towns to do it so
it's no longer we be no longer at their
option thank
discussion seeing none the motion before
us is to accept Amendment 2025
5 71h to House Bill 284 FN if you are in
favor of accepting the amendment you
will vote Yes if you are opposed to
accepting the amendment you will vote no
the clerk will call the
role Vice chairman McDonald yes
please representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk vote Yes
representative France
yes representative karinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes Representative stavis
no representative Gilman
no Representative majori
no representative frock
no representative Colby
no representative jamna
no representative Gerard
yes the motion passes with a vote of 10
to8 the committee recommendation on how
Bill 284 FN is ought to pass with
Amendment the
chair closes the executive session on
House Bill 284 F oh sorry I I skipped
some steps okay sorry okay so that will
go on to the regular
chair that is
correct I apologize I I lost track of
where we
were Madam
chair yes uh I'd like to uh offer otpa
on HB 284 FN is there a second Madam
chair um representative kazinski I'd
like to second that um representative
kazinski seconds
that um representative McDonald would
you like to speak to your motion
I no thank you R I'll rely on my
previous
statements is there further comments or
discussion representative
grund thank you madam chair um one of
the one of the issues I do have with
this and I I could have spoken out the
amendment it it just I remembered it
says on line 181 19 and 20 in multi-
toown districts the notation shall be
included for each town by prefixing the
notation with the name of each town in a
school district similar to exitor that
has five or six towns you're now going
to list five or six towns is this the
one I
don't it's very confusing because that
will cause a cost to the towns when you
have warrant articles that you're going
to have five or six towns and I'm not
voting like even in soan I'm not voting
on what Mont Vernon's tax rate is as a
Schoolboard member trust me we talk
about it a lot but as a voter you're
voting on your impact to your town
issues further comments representative
Colby is recognized thank you madam
chair um kind of piggybacking on uh
representative
grund we need to really consider what
this looks like um Timberlane is four
communities this also calls for all of
this posting to be done under up to
5year contracts four communities Time 5
years is 20 notation of
rates Governor Wentworth seven
communities 35 rates would be required
to be
posted pemy Baker eight communities 40
rates to be
posted it is an
exceptionally exceptionally long ballot
you are creating uh which is borderline
and unfunded mandate onto communities
for printing
um and just in general reviewing uh and
making sure that all of these rates are
accurate who is going to spend the
time thank
you thank you further comments
representative majori is recognized
thank you madam chairwoman um I always
like the idea of transparency which is
why we discussed these things at so many
different meetings from September
through right through March um I could
almost swallow the idea of putting the
estimated tax impact on there what I
would really be curious to see and I
don't know if nhma could do this or
anybody could do this let's see how many
warrant articles pass this year and then
after this bill passes when you have the
total tax impact summary statement at
the beginning how many warrant articles
fail the following year people are going
to see a total tax impact at the
beginning and say I don't want my taxes
going up by a dollar two I'm voting no
on everything I'll bet that's going to
happen further
discussion representative
grunt actually I want to thank uh
representative majori for bringing that
up because you know one of the things
that I'm observing today is that there
are multiple bills in front of us asking
us to change or increase requirements
for reporting voting warn
articles I would say if you sit in on
Town meetings if you sit on school board
meetings we talk about all this
information constantly we talk about it
we present it at at public hearings at
deliberative um printed voter guides um
it just my observation is there's an
opinion people only vote because there's
a tax impact to themselves um or because
something's not going their way in their
own town I I believe many people also
need to assess the quality of the
program and the warrant article um and
representative stavis is
recognized thank you madam chair um I
disagree with this bill for all of the
reasons mentioned by my colleagues but I
would also like to add that I view this
electioneering further comments
discussion seeing none the motion before
us is ought to pass with Amendment on
House Bill
284 if you are in favor of that motion
you will vote Yes if you are opposed to
the motion you will vote no clerk will
call the
role Vice chairman
McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk votes
yes representative France
yes representative karasinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes Representative stavis
no representative Gilman
no Representative majori
no representative frock
no representative Colby
no represent represenative Jana
no representative Gerard
no Representative grund
yes the motion passes with a vote of 10
to8 the committee recommendation on
House Bill 284 FN is ought to pass with
Amendment
that report will go on the regular
calendar and who will write the majority
report I will Madam chair representative
McDonald in Minority Report be
representative Jama thank
you and with that the chair closes the
next the chair opens the executive
oh I'm sorry I thought I thought you
were had a question so I I'm gonna I'm
going to rewind okay oh
okay the chair will open the executive
session on House Bill 495 FN requiring
cities and towns to provide a breakdown
of tax changes in information on bills
sent to
Residents the chair recognizes
representative Davis
thank you madam chair I move itl on this
bill based on a number of reasons but
primarily the fact that the sponsor
never showed up to defend his bill or to
answer
questions is there a second I will
second rep representative Colby seconds
that representative
Davis did you want to speak to your
motion believe I already did but um yeah
we we should have done that myself want
but
no so um we normally speak to the motion
after a second yeah we both messed up
that's okay that's no
problem further comments discussion
representative Colby thank you madam
chair uh this bill would mandate changes
uh to be made to assessing software many
municipalities have existing contracts
that will have to take on additional
Financial burdens
um very expensive software updates will
have to be
undertaken there's also a lack of
guidance on how to deal with
reassessments and variation in bills
that are delivered quarterly or by
anually there is no Direction um as to
if we're providing individual breakdowns
personalized for each property or
overall tax rate changes uh and we of
course heard in testimony uh that
through nhma and Avatar Associates
question the accuracy of the fiscal note
uh and nhma has no record that anyone uh
from their organization actually did
provide
input Avatar and Associates are
concerned that the $10,000 estimate uh
in cost was far too low thank
you thank you further comments
representative Dolan is recognized thank
you madam chair I think in in this case
as as uh in other cases that we've come
across I think we have one further down
our l list to talk about is the public
hearing process that we undertake we
have we have a a sacred I believe a
sacred obligation to share with the with
our constituents and the voters what
we're doing what laws we're we're
looking at enacting uh and we go we do
that through the public hearing process
where we invite the the sponsors of a
bill to explain what the bill is all
about and for us to ask questions imp
pulse the sponsors and co-sponsors so
that we can get a further understanding
and help share with the voters what
their government is doing in a case like
this when none of the when the sponsor
and the co-sponsors don't show up for
the public hearing then that process I
believe becomes contaminated with a lack
of transparency to the voters and so in
this case where there's a no-show for
both the sponsor and the co-sponsors I
don't think we have any other choice but
to itl the
comments I have a few comments with
regards to this this bill and
and it needs work it's not ready for
prime time um one example would be
multip with regards to if there's
multiple school districts and and
potentially multiple um village
districts that's that's not a addressed
in this bill additionally it's my
opinion that um providing tax rate
information is only part of the story I
don't find that to be particularly a
useful
metric
um and
also I am aware of the fact that there's
um okay
that um seeks to to do a similar uh
thing with regards to providing
information however that Senate bill um
has this information to be posted online
at a on a town website or School website
which I think is a a much more practical
way to um address what's being proposed
in this
seeing none the motion before us is in
expedient to legislate on House Bill 495
FN if you are in favor of the motion you
will vote Yes if you are opposed to the
motion you will vote no the clerk will
call the
role Vice chairman
McDonald
yes representative Guthrie yes
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk votes
yes representative France
yes representative karasinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative Gilman
yes representative
majori
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerana
yes representative Gerard
yes representative grunt
the motion passes with a vote of 18 to
zero the committee recommendation on
House Bill 495 FN is expedient
inexpedient to legislate without
objection
oh yeah we we can put this on the um
consent calendar so without objection
the recommendation will go on to the
house consent
calendar and the committee report report
by Madam chair I'll write that report
that would be representative Murphy
thank you madam chair there's a fiscal
note on this Bill yes thank thank you
thank you for pointing that out
um it recently came to to my attention
and my um previous understanding with
regards to bills with fiscal notes and
which calendar it's to go on is that it
is acceptable to place a bill with a
fiscal note on the consent calendar if
the motion is inexpedient to
legislate so but I do appreciate that
check on on on the
you I need to answer a question before I
there's a question as to who seconded
the motion was it representative
you
correct and with that the chair closes
next the chair will open the executive
session on House Bill 6113 relative to
enabling local political subdivisions to
vote and set a reduced default budget
option do I have a motion Madam chair
representative kazinski is recognized
for a motion I'd like to make an motion
to amend with 2025 d07 95h House Bill
613 so your your motion is to
accept the amendment to the house bill
is there a second Madame chair I will
second that representative Murphy
seconds that representative
motion yes this amendment just uh
clarifies language in it to allow uh
local political subdivisions to adopt
Provisions for an annual choice of
reduced default
comments representative stavis has
recognized oh
oh okay because I when I looked to my
left I thought the arm was attached to
representative
stavis
okay representative majority is
recognized thank you madam
chairwoman the ability of an effective
governing body to manage The Prudent
Affairs of their Community depends upon
their capacity to be responsive to the
unique quality of life and culture
within their Community when local
officials make decisions they are
carrying out the policy values set forth
by the majority of residents the policy
values set forth by the majority give
the governing B bodies purpose and
direction this is yet another bill that
if passed will undermine prudent
management of local Affairs thwart the
will of the majority increase the
influence of special interest groups and
local government and create barriers to
repealing errors in harmful rules and
actions and therefore I'm opposed to
both the amendment and the underlying
you okay further
discussion okay I'm going to go to this
side first representative Elwood is
recognized thank you madam
chairman
um this is a question or I'm just musing
out loud is representative majority
reading from his own words or is he
referencing something that was written
elsewhere
sorry I'm well I'm thinking right now um
I I I'm inclined
to this is why I'm
hesitating I'm inclined to find that
inquiry by the representative
um somewhat
inappropriate so what I will say is that
the representative to whom the inquiry
was
directed um may choose not to respond or
if the representative chooses to respond
you can be
recognized thank you madam chairwoman at
uh 10:05 yesterday I finished uh Penning
these comments which are mine and mine
alone thank
you thank you representative further um
discussion representative stavis is
recognized thank you madam chair I just
have to
say that why are we discounting simple
majority votes I I just don't understand
why we don't trust the simple majority
of our constituents to vote and we're
insisting that three fifths of them have
to vote in the affirmative or the
negative in order to prove the point I
think that is anti-democratic I think
that it is burdensome and I I just I
think that it is uncalled for and
unwarranted and an illegitimate
expression of Power by the state
legislature on individual cities and
towns that have their own needs their
own Cates in their own priorities thank
you further discussion representative
col's
recognized thank you madam chair um I
have the most troubling part of
listening uh to the testimony was the
implication um that we need to offer a
third type of
budget uh warrant article budgetary
warrant article uh was because there was
a slim Financial difference
between a default budget and a presented
operating
budget um I it is in my experience the
reason that you don't see a big
variation between these two figures is
because school districts and
municipalities towns are working hard at
delivering budgets that are reflective
of the needs um of their community and
respecting the burden that is taken on
by taxpayers already to set forth a
third budget
option um that is just an arbitrary
figure uh is and thinking about the
cative damage of
that um is beyond
comprehension residents will will see a
degradation and services uh and quality
of care as the missing money has to come
from somewhere municipalities are
strictly service based they're strictly
there to provide services they don't
make
money uh towns cannot decide to carry a
different product to reduce their cost
they can't decide uh to Outsource uh
production overseas um the only way to
make arbitrary Cuts uh that are not
suggested by your elected officials or
your town
officials um it's reduce services that
our residents depend on thank you
further
discussion representative grund is
recognized thank you madam chairwoman um
so picking backing on representative
Colby I am I believe default budget
calculations need to be worked on yes I
do but this is not the way to present a
um it's not based on facts it's not
based on actual information it's going
back to um asking people to vote on a
tax rate impact and not assess the
programs um themselves I you know part
of the critical thinking skills we teach
in schools are to understand the source
and the motivation many towns and
schools are doing a thorough job
educating residents through meetings
that include public comments public
hearing ings deliberative sessions
documentation that's mailed to voters
and holding extra meetings as needed on
important topics such as bonds school
districts and town leaders are not
hiding information and we need to get
back to open discussions and Trust in
our towns and school leaders I am
against this amendment and look forward
motion thank you representative stavis
is recognized thank you madam chair uh I
have a question actually on the
amendment and it's line 18 and 19
where it says only votes in the
affirmative or negative shall be
included in the
representative Kosinski y I could offer
a potential answer to that question
thank you madam chair um I think if
people come in and register to vote and
don't vote you could have 1500
people in attendance and if 500 vote
for
and 800 vote against
that's how you f figure your
three-fifths calculation you wouldn't
include the 200 people that are also
there not voting I believe that's what
that's trying to answer thank you but
there is no language in the bill that
says
discussion seeing none the motion before
2025-the of accepting the amendment you
will vote Yes if you are not in favor of
accepting the amendment you will vote no
role Vice chairman McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk vote
Yes representative France yes
representative Kosinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes Representative stavis
no representative Gilman
no Representative majori
no representative frock
no representative Colby
no representative
[Music]
no representative Gerard
no Representative grundt
2025-the
of 10 to8 do I have a motion
Madam chair representative Kosinski is
recognized thank you I'll make a motion
ought to pass with
amendment is there a second Madame chair
I'll will second that represent car
thank you is representative Kosinski
would you like to speak to your
motion I'll defer to the uh Prime
sponsor or
chair I'm sorry the sponsor of the
amendment
h
so House Bill 613 this is enabling
legislation for SP2 towns and school
districts that allows for an an option
to put forward a reduced default budget
by a fixed percentage that is specified
when
um when this provision is is approved
there are issues as another
representative had um stated with
regards to default budgets in this bill
is um legislation that seeks to address
the um problems and the
budgets so what that means is if the
proposed budget does not pass in an sb2
town or School District that there's of
course there's a default budget but
there's if this is enabling
legislation is passed that it allows for
like I said the reduced default
budget and what this bill seeks to do is
to prevent the biggest problem with
default budgets is monitor ionically
increasing default budgets so
I I support this bill and I I it's an
important bill to to
um remedy the issues um in
SP2 further
discussion representative Gilman thank
you madam chair I I understand that this
is enabling uh legislation but I do
wonder about line 20 that says the
question shall not be amended uh by the
legislative body and I am curious how it
is that we go to a public town meeting
but aren't allowed to um to vote on
something different than what is
presented further
discussion representative
majori and I I it was a question
question that was asked before I guess
I'm asking it again but won't look for
year that seems dangerous
thanks further comments or discussion
representative grund thank you madam
chairwoman so one of the reasons default
budgets are so close to budgets is
because we try not to add that much
extra unless there's a need that's why
many times you see extra special warrant
articles because you don't necessarily
put in your budget but you ask the town
do you want to do this as a separate
issue if you go to a percentage there
are contractual obligations and things
that need to be met like special
education that if you start cutting it
by 8% 10% yeah you're going to start
impacting your education and I would
certainly hope the town people voters
that are showing up have educated
themselves on the budget has shown up
this is just another way to to just
attack
schools for representative stavis is
recognized thank you madam chair now I
have an enormous amount of respect for
the combined expertise and experience of
all of the legislators on this
committee um they all hold um local have
local responsibilities many of them hold
local offices and I I just I simply
cannot
support bill after Bill after Bill that
seeks to
subvert and and the way locally
elected officials can or cannot do their
jobs and I wonder why given the the very
proud history that this legislature has
has put into place a very fine level of
balance between legislative Authority
and local control always deferring to on
the side of local control that all of a
sudden we need to pass a raft of bills
that tie the hands of locally elected
officials and confuse their constituents
I just I don't understand
it and I can't support it further
discussion
okay seeing none the motion before us is
ought to pass with Amendment on House
Bill
6113 if you are in favor of the motion
you will vote Yes if you are opposed to
the motion you will vote no clerk will
role Vice chairman
McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk votes yes representative
France
yes representative Kosinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes Representative stavis
no representative Gilman
no Representative majori
no representative frock no
representative Colby
no Representative gerna
no representative Gerard
no representative grunt
yes the motion passes with a vote of 10
to8 the committee recommendation on
House Bill 613 is a to pass with
calendar and I will volunteer to write
the report and that would be the M
majority report and The Minority Report
looks like it will be written by
oh
okay representative Gilman will write
thank you and with that the executive s
the chair will now open the executive
session on House Bill 475
local relative to the reductions from
the default budget for the official
ballot Town
meetings mam chair representative Dolan
is recognized to propose an
amendment to this bill amendment number
568 is there a second I'll second that
representative France seconds that is
representative Dolan would you like to
speak to your
motion
discussion okay
okay which arm do I
see representative Gilman's arm I see so
recognized Bill oh thank you madam chair
I'm afraid that I was out at the time
that this bill was amended um so I
haven't seen it and I do not feel uh
thank you representative majori is
recognized thank you madam
chairwoman the ability of an effective
governing body to manage The Prudent
Affairs of their Community depends on
their capacity to be responsive to the
unique quality in life of life and
culture within their Community when
local officials make decisions they are
carrying out the policy values set forth
by the majority of residents the policy
values set by the majority give the
governing body purpose and Direction
this is yet another in a raft of bad
bills that have passed undermine The
Prudent management of local Affairs
thwart the will of the majority increase
the influ influence of special interest
groups groups and local government and
create barriers to repealing errors and
harmful rules and actions I am opposed
to the amendment and the underlying Bill
thank
discussion representative Elward is
recognized
thank you madam chairman I believe that
when someone delivers a statement with
authority that they should preface it
with in my personal
[Music]
comments I i' I'd like to make I'd like
to make a a comment so this portion of
the executive
session is to comment with regards to
legislation in with regards to an
amendment or a
bill I would
kindly ask that members
um focus on
that
issue as
legislators and refrain from
commentary with regards
[Music]
to how somebody's offering discussion or
comments with regards to the work that
we're doing here that is
legislation representative stavis is
recognized thank you madam chair in my
opinion this legislature has
historically upheld a balance between
what it dictates to cities and
towns and what it leaves to local
control and that bance has always aired
on the side of local control and why we
are
today in over the course of a few hours
and over the course of five or six
bills erasing that history I simply have
no idea and I cannot support any of
comments seeing none the motion before
25-06 if you are in favor of accepting
the amendment then you will vote Yes if
you are opposed to accepting the
amendment you will vote no the clerk
will call the
role Vice chairman McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan yes
representative Elward
yes the clerk vote
Yes representative France
yes representative karasinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes Representative stavis
no representative Gilman
no Representative majori
no representative frock
no representative Colby
no representative Jana
no representative Gerard
no Representative grund
yes Amendment 2025
d6h to House Bill
475 is accept CED with a vote of 10
motion I'd like to make a motion of
Amendment representative France moves
ought to pass with amendment is there a
second Madame chair I'll second that
representative Bella BR seconds that
would you like to speak to your motion
representative FS um not at this time
thank you is
there further discussion or comments
representative Colby is recognized thank
you madam chair in my humble opinion uh
we should not be creating legislation
based on the assumption that unused
money budgeted for positions is being
used
recklessly it is more likely that this
money is being utilized to offset
overtime lines or contracted
Services HB 475 even as amended seems to
be borne from baseless accusations of
Fraud and Abuse of public funds by
municipalities and school
districts this bill asks municipalities
and school districts both to look into
crystal balls and see the
future uh no one can really predict when
a police officer a firefighter or a
special education teacher teacher will
apply for or be granted employment nor
can school districts predict when a
child with unique needs may move into
their District public schools are
legally required to provide services to
these children regardless of their
approved budgets and in some cases this
involves hiring experienced Personnel at
hat further comments uh represent ative
grund is recognized thank you madam
chairwoman and uh outside of the
headcount issues that were just uh
discussed um if we're going to work on
default budgets we need to consider
those things that are required by law
like Transportation Transportation
required by law for k through eight
let's include that in there utility
increases we've all seen enormous
utility increases we're not allowed to
include those in here we had an $80,000
increase this year and if we're in
default budget we got to go find that
money so if we're going to work on
default budget let's do it correctly and
please again what uh representative
Colby said is let's put some trust in
the people that were elected that they
are working hard there are ways and
means committees Finance committees
budget committees whatever your town or
municipality calls it and uh there are
open discussions thank you thank you
further discussion representative Elward
thank you madam
chairman um I'm really jealous of
Representatives who live in what I call
civilized
towns um to give you an example of lack
of transparency in one of my district
towns uh they're trying to pass a $3.2
million Bond based on a single sheet of
paper um that was mailed to
voters um and despite exposing the fact
that no estimated cost breakdown
has
been publicized or
created um I'm sorry but there are towns
that want to
hide um what they're doing and do not
disclose to the the citizens what they
disclose representative Colby is
recognized thank you madam chair
respectfully um representative that's
what Municipal elections should be doing
um and if that is not the
case
[Music]
then I would think that that is the
electorate still speaking to what they
would
like representative
stavis thank you madam chair I strongly
object in my opinion to the question
just put forward by representative award
it has nothing to do with the bill at
hand it has everything to do with a
personal grievance against one town that
is not what we are here to do that is
do further comments representative
grundt thank you again Madam chairwoman
so in my
opinion boards School boards Town boards
all have public meetings bonds require
public hearings
uh there's separate public hearings for
before deliberative sessions all that
information has to be produced for a
public hearing that includes all of that
as a discussion
so again I I do agree it's it it should
not be a grievance against one town it
should it's I mean that's just the law
that has to happen so I don't understand
what's not being followed thank
you further comments or discussion
representative Gilman is recognized
thank you madam chair um I would just
like to
um add on to representative stavis and
grunt's comments and say that it is not
fair to change a law for the entire
state for a problem that has to be
solved
locally further comments representative
stavis is recognized thank thank you
madam chair and um thanks to my
colleague representative Gilman for
reminding me in our opinion and it has
been the opinion of this committee for
as many years as I have had the
privilege of serving on it that we do
not make state law that only applies to
individual towns or certain
municipalities that is not what voters
sent us here to do and it is not what we
should be doing further
comments representative lward is
recognized yes I just want to State for
the record that I use that as an
example and that I have heard from
numerous towns
people um
of what I can only call
Shenanigans
to keep the
people
oppressed and so again I just use that
comments I'd like to make one comment
the the bill as amended absolutely
upholds and maintains that
any oblig
obligations required by law are
supported in the default budget and
secondly I would like to state that I do
agree with representative stavis that it
is completely inappropriate to be
passing legislation that pertains to a
single individual or or a single um
situation that being
said this bill before
us pertains to default budgets under sb2
the official ballot referendum form of
town
meetings and to be clear there are
numerous towns and school districts with
spb2 and
therefore this legislation before us
pertains to legislation that is
currently on the books in the state and
moreover it pertains to
many towns and school districts with
sb2 representative majori is recognized
thank you madam
chairwoman online 13 support
184 opposed I'm not hearing a need for a
Statewide
I would have a further comment um I
support this bill with Amendment because
this bill closes numerous
loopholes and IT addresses the the
deficiencies and problems with the
default budget and the purpose of a
default budget as compared to the um
proposed budget a default budget is
supposed to be a more Bare Bones basic
budget so for those reasons I support
comments
no seeing none the motion before us is
ought to pass with Amendment on House
Bill
475 local if you are in favor of that
motion you will vote Yes yes if you are
opposed to that motion you will vote no
the clerk will call the
role Vice chairman McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes clerk votes
yes representative France
yes representative karasinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes Representative stavis
no representative Gilman
no Representative majori
no representative frock
no representative Colby no thank
you Representative jamana
no representative Gerard no
Representative grund
yes the motion passes with a vote of 10
to8 the committee recommendation on
House Bill 475 local is ought to pass
with
amendment that will go on the regular
calendar
and I will volunteer to write the
majority report who would like to author
The Minority Report representative Colby
thank
you and with that the chair closes the
executive session on House Bill 475
local
at this time the chair will open the
how okay I shouldn't look to my left
when I'm trying to open the executive
session
rewind at this time the chair will open
the executive session on House Bill 228
local relative to petitioned articles at
meeting Madame chair uh yes
representative Elward is recognized um
I'd like to make a
motion I'd like to
[Music]
225-8008 to House Bill 228 local is
there yes is there a second yeah I'll
second that representative McDonald
seconds that uh represent of Elwood
would you like to speak to your motion
um I would like to defer items one
through four to the prime sponsor of the
bill and I would like to speak to items
just um this thank you representative
though so the amendment before
the
which address is the issues that were
raised by representative Elwood during
the during the
hearing and the
focus so would you could you speak to
your Amendment and the issue that that
you brought up during the hearing and
how you addressed it with the
amendment okay regarding um item
five under the Planning and Zoning
title um um
this uh Roman
1 this adds uh the language the peti on
line 36 starting the petition shall
identify one of the petitioners as a
primary
petitioner um so we've invented the word
or the term primary
petitioner um that goes on through Roman
um whereas the planning board
chairman uh shall give the primary
petitioner the opportunity to introduce
the petitioned amendment at a public
hearing and that the primary petitioner
shall be given 10 minutes for this
introduction um and the the primary
petitioner May designate any other of
the uh petitioners as a primary
petitioner um it also makes the primary
petitioner
responsible for the cost of notice by
mail um of the hearing for their
petitioned
amendment I think that covers it thank
you is there are there further
thank you madam chairwoman I'm hoping to
get some clarification um throughout the
rest of this on all petition warant
articles it gives the length of time is
um I I can't find exactly but the length
the longest length of if any other um
article is being presented that it gives
them the longest the same length of time
as the longest but yet for zoning it's
only 10 minutes why are we making a
differentiation rather than saying 10
I did not write the language for items 1
through 4 the amended language for items
1 through
4 and so a minimum of 10 minutes um
seems reasonable as opposed to 3 minutes
that you know some people seem to think
can I just have a quick
followup
could
yes um the clarification I'm looking for
is uh for a petition warrant article in
other instances they're given a long
long length of time
potentially but the zoning is only 10
minutes so yes I agree with you 3
minutes is not enough I I get the 10 but
we're differentiating a different amount
of time for each group and I'm just
category I I'll respond to to to your
inquiries with regards to to the
amendment
um what we're the section that we're
looking at here right now has to do with
um a hearing which is very different
than an annual meeting and and therefore
um the structure and and what occurs is
is different so that is why um the 10
minutes at least 10 minutes it doesn't
mean that the that the individual needs
to utilize the 10 minutes so that's
that's why
that's that's why that's different um
than the bill as as referred to the
committee further comments
seeing none the motion before us is to
accept
Amendment
d00
0800h
if
what if you're in favor of accepting the
amendment then you will vote Yes if you
are opposed to accepting the amendment
then you will vote no the clerk will
call the
role Vice chairman
McDonald uh I vote no I'm going to vote
you representative
Guthrie
no representative Walker
no Representative stavis
no representative Gilman
no Representative majori
no representative frock
no representative Colby
no Representative gerana
2025-the vote of two to what was it 2 to
16 do I have another motion
representative stavis is recognized for
a
motion thank you madam chair I'd like to
move ought to pass on HB
second representative majori seconds
that representative stavis would you
like to speak to your motion thank you
madam chair this committee has a proud
tradition of upholding bills that
advocate for members of the Public
Public to speak freely at public
meetings and this bill adds to that
ability further comments representative
majority is recognized thank you madam
chairwoman um I do support this bill for
a little bit of a different reason in my
three years on the budget committee and
15 years on the uh on the select board
I've seen a lot of people uh present
petition Warren article
and then no one speak to them I don't
expect everyone to be in order when they
get up there or be comfortable with
public speaking I don't expect that at
all but I do expect somebody to speak to
the article and not just default to a
petition warrant article goes on the
ballot so for those reasons or for that
reason I support this Bill thank you
further discussion or comments
representative Gilman is
recognized thank you madam
chair excuse me um my community
already does this and it's very simple
the application for a a petitioned
warrant are uh our public documents and
uh um we present them with our budget
with our warrant our voting warrant and
so those names are on a public list and
if someone wants to know why they went
ahead and signed that list um they can
get that clarified at the default
meeting
further
discussion seeing none the motion before
us is ought to pass on House Bill 228
local if you are in favor of the motion
you will vote Yes if you are opposed to
the motion you will vote no the clerk
will call the
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative
Elward
yes the clerk votes
yes representative France
yes representative karasinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative stavis
yes representative
Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerana
yes representative Gerard
yes representative grund
the motion passes with a vote of 18 to Z
the committee recommendation on House
Bill 228 local will be ought to pass and
without objection that will go on the
calendar and who will write the majority
report
oh representative majority thank
no I'm
sorry
repres maybe that arm can write the
report
for for representative majori okay okay
representative Gilman will write the
committee report correct
thank
you and with that um the chair closes
we're just chatting here about lunch
we're going back and forth do we take
lunch or we do we do one more bill so I
think we'd like to do one more uh exec
one more
bill so with that the chair will open
the executive session on House Bill 168
relative to including Municipal Public
Works facilities as eligible Capital
motion
well representative majori is recognized
for a motion thank you madam chairwoman
I move ought to pass on House Bill 168
thank you is there a second
representative grun seconds second oh
thank you representative majori would
you like to speak to your
motion yes well given that um I'm a
co-sponsor on this there was a time
where I thought this was a great bill
that continues through today and I do
think that it makes perfect sense to
include Public Works
facilities um in um for impact fees uh
and I think of my own Community where
that Public Works facility is on a Town
border um and is going to be renovated
and sits on a considerable piece of land
uh I think considering considering
impact fees is very logical so for that
reason I support the Bill thank you
further comments or
discussion seeing none the motion before
us is ought to pass on House Bill 168 if
you are in favor of the motion you will
vote Yes if you are opposed to the
motion you will vote no the clerk will
call the
role Vice chairman Donald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk votes
yes representative France
yes representative Kosinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker yes
representative stavis sorry
yes representative Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerana
yes representative Gerard
yes representative grund
yes the motion passes with a vote of 18
to Z the committee recommendation on
House Bill 168 is ought to pass and that
will go on the house consent calendar
without objection and representative
majority would you like to write the
report thank you and with that the chair
closes the executive session on House
so at this time I I think the committee
would very much like to take go take
lunch so we will reconvene at 1:00 to
continue executive sessions on the
you
e
good afternoon the municipal and County
government committee
has finished their lunch and we will
continue with executive sessions on the
remaining bills that we have publicly
noticed so at this time the chair will
open the executive session on House Bill
124 enabling a city or town Forest
committee to offer Surplus money to the
town for deposit in the city or town
general
fund do I have a motion representative
France is recognized for a motion yes
I'd like to make a motion to accept the
amendment number uh
[Music]
2025-the
France would you like to speak to your
[Music]
motion I I think this amendment is is
just very simple um it's taking it gives
the
town um the opportunity to take money
that they've appropriated to a
Conservation Commission or a forestry
committee um it can be offered if
there's a surplus in the account at the
end of a period it can be offered back
to the town to accept and put into their
uh unreserved fund balance um which is a
lot better than going into a general
fund for sure
and it's totally optional so I think
it's a a good amendment is there any
discussion or comments on
this representative majority is
recognized thank you madam chairwoman
and I I I do believe I I like where this
is trying to go and I want to get there
my question is on line 14 we say a
conservation committee and I and I
believe that needs to say Conservation
Commission I don't think there's
anything as a conservation
committee so it's actually a question a
general question is that something that
if we accept the
amendment can be can be changed uh
administratively or would there need to
be an amendment if that is true that it
needs to be commission rather than
committee thank you representative
majority um when when you ask if it can
well first of all we know that this was
drafted by ol
so it it appears to be that that is
um an oversight in in the wording so um
as to the ability to Simply um make that
change between now and when it goes to
um could you know here in the house we
the other chamber has the ability
through their their house rules to to do
what you're exactly what you're asking I
am unaware of the ability in the house
to do that okay I've
um may be something that's that's like
latent hidden that I don't know about
but um I've never never seen it but what
I would like to um offer or suggest is
that if this bill were to go forward and
were to go over to the other chamber um
the it certainly could be amended over
there and it it should be thank you
further
comments representative
Colby um thank you madam chair uh during
the
presentation um I and and I'm still
confused as to
why they would be
unable they being a town Forest
committee would be unable to do this
um because it seems like the statute
already reads that they should be able
to and if for some reason a personal or
not a personal but uh in in the case of
the town of arrel uh which we heard
about
[Music]
um generally this is done with
contacting Town Council uh maybe
reaching out to nhma creating a warrant
article that dissolves their current
fund um appropriating the money into the
general fund or unexpended fund balance
um and then reestablishing a new process
that better suits their needs I feel
like there's already there's already a
mechanism available and I could be
mistaken but I I can see nothing in the
current statute that would
prevent them from doing this um
um and then I just have concerns that it
doesn't Set uh out any mechanics as to
how um the forestry committee would
officially decide to offer the
Surplus um there's no official vote
that's taken it's just an arbitrary
offer and then I would ask that people
do keep in mind that even if the
governing
body is allocated These funds they are
not obligated
to use this offered Surplus
through this particular
bill um to offset property taxes with
the money um so there's no obligation by
the governing body to do that within the
bill representative
stavis thank you madam chair in addition
to the concerns that were just
raised I am looking at the RSA that this
bill seeks to amend which is RSA 31
colon 113 oh wait pardon I may have to
resend that
sorry further looking at the Rong okay
further
comments represented
majori thank you madam chairwoman again
um I'm not sure if it would be
appropriate or inappropriate or even
accept it but I was speaking with the
prime sponsor of the bill and the prime
sponsor of the amendment
and if I at lunch and if I understood
him
correctly and I would be wondering of
the of the chair if it would be okay for
him to speak but that that Council said
they need this language in order to do
what they want to do because they went
down all the
Avenues that they tried to and they were
told you can't unless you have this
language even though it seems like they
can and and I don't know I I don't know
that I'm quoting the the uh the sponsor
correctly so I and I like I said I don't
know if it would be permissible to have
the sponsor respond to
that thank you representative um
normally individuals don't provide input
at executive
sessions but um due to the fact that
there's um some confusion with regards
to this uh Amendment and I do see the
prime sponsor here I will um permit the
prime sponsor
to um respond to your
Davis yes thank you madam chair and
thank you representative majori majori
for uh allowing me to asking me to speak
here um I I honestly it's above my pay
grade to know why this can't be done
simply I read it the same way you do in
the town
uh I believe that was a clerical error
as well from OS put not putting
commission I I overlook that as well but
talking with the the forestry Committee
in arrol they've they've tried several
times all these different Avenues Dr
tells them if you know they they put in
their request and they give them the
ability to yes or no you can spend it
for that the three things their Forest
is set up for buying more land which
they have 8,500 Acres they're not
interested in buying more maintaining
their land and they do that they do that
at a very high level and the other one
they can spend it in the town as long as
it has something to do with with helping
their Forest like one year they bought a
fire truck for the town now they do
timber Harvest annually and that money's
accumulating and they have no place to
spend it and the ENT of this from the
beginning was once they got to this
point they would like to use some of
that money for tax relief they need to
keep certain amount in their account to
maintain their forest or if something
comes up like that but any
surplus this would allow either that
Conservation Commission or the forestry
committee to if they deem there is a
surplus they can offer it to the select
board to put in a warrant article that
the legislative body which would be the
town at a town meeting would vote to put
that into the uh into this fund that
they could spend the money on so and it
would create tax
relief so the there's checks and
balances all the way through I I can I
mean I don't know all the procedes
either I can check with the clerk but uh
if this if that committee could be
changed to community commission a
Conservation Commission in the Senate I
would be all over that
uh but other than that I I've been to Dr
myself myself reading that I said well
it looks
like you're able to do it it looks like
you could spend the money anyway you
want but it doesn't I I see it different
than the attorneys and so I asked uh his
name is Adam denor at Dr what what would
I need to make this work for this town
and he said well you need this some kind
of language like this and then I worked
with the chair to tweak it a little bit
and and this is what we came up with uh
what the problem's going to be is you'll
have some towns are set up differently
like the town that I live
in I don't ask me why I'm I'm not a I I
cut wood myself so I'm not
a a college educated or anything like
that but I I do not know why they they
can't do it when I read the RSA it looks
like sure that's acceptable but they
told me no it had the language has to be
changed so that it gives them the
thank you representative Davis you
addressed you addressed um
representative majority's question this
is not a hearing this is an ex no not
you it's for these people over here this
is not a hearing it's an executive
session so the representative Davis will
not take further
questions um I'm assuming that you here
have comments with with regards to the
bill correct so the chair will recognize
representative
Murphy thank you madam
chair since this is an unapproved uh
Amendment why can't we change the one
word from committee to commission since
it's unapproved already just a question
you know so representative Murphy that
is not how things work here in the house
we request drafts ahead of the executive
session OSS drafts an amendment in its
unapproved language there is no time
that representative
stavis would you agree with with with
this
um thank you madam chair I actually have
been in exec sessions where someone has
fed an amendment to OS and request a
change so uh so I I
respectfully I've not I've had the
experience where an emergency change has
been made but I'm not saying that's
appropriate in this case I'm just saying
I have had that experience just
so with respect to the ranking member I
I completely agree with that and I did
not want to make an executive decision
that we would do exactly what you had
just
um outlined
without discussion so I I would be fine
with that if that would um satisfy the
the concerns with regards to the
amendment
we
um we we could certainly um do
that representive stavis sorry you
opened the
door but um if we did do that then I
would
request in line 17 that the word shall
be changed to
May the governing body should not be
required to accept the
Surplus If This truly is enabling that
should be May so if we look at the
amendment on line 15 it says with
regards to the surface the committee may
offer may offer the Surplus it's not
saying the committee shall offer for the
Surplus and I think to I was referring
to I'm getting there okay and so with
regards to I think representative Colby
had had asked a question with regards to
um the procedure so lines 16 and 17 says
that the legislative body shall vote and
to me that clearly implies that the the
offer of monies will be on warrant
article and and and and therefore that
it's to be voted upon by the legislative
funds yes so um I hope that makes I hope
I hope that clarifies things for you
representative Colby thank you madam
chair my question was more in how the
how these separate committees are making
that determination um you know if you go
into a committee meeting and how many
are saying yes let's send the Surplus
are are we and how are they approving
that are they taking a vote in official
meeting minutes um and then of course
you know down the line the legislative
body would either accept or not um
representative Colby my response would
be yes to all of your statements that
would be the procedure that's the normal
operating
committee further comments
representative
Guthrie thank thank you madam chair uh I
have a question why on on the amendment
why we Chang from the uh general fund to
the unreserved fund balance why is it
it was it was changed to unreserved fund
balance to because if the money was put
into the general fund then that money
could be used for just about anything it
would be extra money that that that was
the wasn't
specifically part of the of the process
and if it went into the unreserved fund
balance that it would um more
specifically go back to um as a revenue
and to defer
taxes representative
Dolan thank you madam chair if it uh
went to the general fund then it can be
it could be reallocated by any Town
manager Town Administrator whatever uh
if it goes to the unreserve fun balance
that has to be done by the governing
board not just the administrator or
manager so I think that's the you split
the hairs that's the
difference further
comments if I could
answer Tom commas I agree I I just to me
it didn't make any difference whether uh
PR
least
ased and the mechanism by which each
group for or Conservation
Commission votes
to move the which I don't I don't know
that they
FS you know who is it on the committee
that authorizes this transfer of funds I
think that's the you have there's got to
be some boiler
plate so you
don't live in the
woods
live Stephanie yeah do you want me to do
that do you have a
we're just trying to figure out it's a
revolving F so um at this time where're
we're we're sorting out a few details so
is there a motion to withdraw the a
motion to to accept the the
amendment I'll make that motion
representative McDonald motions to
withdraw the motion to accept the
amendment is there a
that so if you're in favor of
withdrawing the current motion so that
um we could address the issues that just
came up um you'll vote Yes if you're
opposed to that you'll vote no the clerk
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative
Elward yes
the clerk says
yes representative France yes
representative kazinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative Davis
yes representative Gilman
yes representative mag majori yes excuse
me representative frock yes
representative Colby
yes representative gerana
yes representative Gerard
yes representative grund
yes the motion to withdraw the amendment
why don't we just move on to the next
bill and
then
so what we're going to do right now is
we are going to recess the executive
session on House Bill 124 and we will
take it up um before the end of our P of
today yes and um at this point we are
break
e
open the executive session on House Bill
501 FN relative to allowing towns to
Towers Madam chair have a
motion Vice chairman McDonald is
recognized for a
motion my motion is to it this
particular bill is there a
second second
representative Dolan
second Vice chairman McDonald would you
like to speak to your
motion yes uh thank you madam chair this
would ban uh 5G Towers expansion of 5G
in in our local
communities I think we all can recognize
the uh importance of having uh moving
forward with 5G as concerned to uh
individuals businesses industry and uh
the Improvement of our
Telecommunications
uh we'll see uh A reduced time it takes
for uh our messages to travel across the
internet uh we'll have a better
bandwidth increase speed and improve
coverage throughout our
state that's why I'm requesting an itl
on this bill which would uh allow the
communities to ban this uh technology
thank you further comments
discussion representative majori thank
you madam chairwoman um we've seen a lot
of bills or we have a lot of bills that
require empirical evidence I know even
in my own Community we see uh warant
articles that require or ask for
empirical evidence I found that the
testimony from Andrew Thatcher um
provided the kind of empirical evidence
that allows me to support the itl motion
he was very thorough and his written
testimony was compelling thank you
so one of the concerns that I have with
regards to this bill as written is that
it repeals in its entirety chapter
12K entitled deployment of personal
wireless service facilities and then it
reenacts that entire section with the
provisions of of the
bill
um that's a concern because it removes
or repeals the goals and the purposes
the
definitions Wireless Provisions for
wireless carriers doing business in the
state payments of cost fall zones
Regional notification application review
and limitations on applications so to me
that's that's that that's a big concern
and
additionally a further concern is that
uh we the state needs to follow the
Telecommunications Act of
1996 so I I'm not really sure what
exactly this bill would would be
accomplishing so for those reasons I
uh representative Dolan thank you madam
chair there is a um there's one El one
aspect of these towers that's really
non-technical that I'd like to speak to
and that is that many uh fire and police
entities piggyback on these five Towers
because there's so many dead spots in
rural areas that we need the height of
these of these tow hours in order to
further the emergency communications
that happened between the fire and
police so uh it's so it's not a 5G issue
but it's a it's a communication issue to
help uh a first responder so in that in
that regard I think uh we ought to try
to help them uh through through the use
of these towers and piggybacking on
these towers thank you further
comments representative
stavis um thank you madam chair and this
is not really a technical comment but
it's kind of an INT an intent comment um
where the the bill title is Municipal
control of 5G Towers but really when you
read the bill all it does is give
municip municipalities the authority to
deny
them there's nothing in the bill that
says they have the authority to allow
them so it it seems it seems a little
bit
unbalanced in what it's trying to
do maybe the the you know it's just
assuming a given conclusion that that
voters may not agree
comments seeing none the motion before
us is inexpedient to legislate on House
Bill 501 FN if you are in favor of the
motion you will vote Yes if you oppose
the motion you will vote no the clerk
will call the
role Vice chairman McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk votes
yes representative France
yes representative Kosinski yes
representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative stavis
yes representative
Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative jamana
yes representative Gerard yes
yes representative grund
yes the motion passes with a vote of 18
to Zer the committee recommendation on
House Bill 51 FN is inexpedient to
legislate and that can and will go on
the house consent calendar because
despite the FN it the motion is
inexpedient to legis L and the majority
report will be written
by I'll do that representative
you and with that the executive session
at this time the chair opens the
executive session on House Bill
471 establishing a commission to study
issues related to growth traffic and
planning of land use for certain towns
do I have a motions yes
um the chair recognizes representative
stavis thank you madam chair would like
to move itl on HB
471 the motion is inexpedient to
legislate is there a
second representative Gilman seconds the
motion representative stavis would you
like to speak to your motion thank you
madam chair yes just a few words um what
this uh Bill attempts to do can already
be done by Regional planning commissions
um it also so it's duplicative and it
will cost the state money in other words
it will cost taxpayers money and it only
applies to a
certain grouping of towns and leaves at
least one town in that Corridor out for
unknown reasons so I believe that it is
a badly written Bill and not unnecessary
Bill thank you further
comments representative Dolan is
recognized thank you madam chair in
addition I believe we have too many
expensive duplicative commissions and
committees in the state and this would
uh unfortunately add to
that thank you further comments
representative Gilman is
recognized thank you madam chair and
this is another bill um it does carve
out those towns the surrounding ones are
um have some commonalities but it's a
it's a
specialty um
and there were no specialty or experts
that um were here to comment or or were
here they didn't know about it and they
didn't have anything to add to this bill
um so I for that that reason that there
was no expertise represented that this
is a donut of a of a Rockingham
Rockingham a planning commission which
does help communities with grants and um
assistance with the uh writing zoning
ordance and transportation plans etc for
those purposes I have to vote itl on
this
discussion I have a few I have a few
comments so my understanding of this
bill is that it is it would create an an
overlay commission to to look look at um
the issues that were outlined in the
bill so I I do um concur with the with
the comments that that were have been
have been made thus far but I would like
to point out that in the
bill on line three it says the
commission shall study um solutions for
growth traffic and planning so to me
that implies for example a traffic study
and the question would be where are we
getting the money to to conduct that
traffic study and when I look at the
bill there's no fiscal note so that's
seems to me very curious uh I don't know
if it was an oversight I don't know I I
just don't know how that would be funded
and um furthermore it's my understanding
with regards to Regional planning
commissions that in fact the director of
the commissions do do meet so the
question that I would have is um why
can't these issues be discussed and
sorted out um at at that level so to me
therefore what this bill is seeking to
do can can already be done without
standing up um
through a stat without setting up or
standing up a statutory commission and
additionally the concern would be with
regards to these commissions it's
already difficult to get people to
volunteer and to participate in
commissions and
um for all those reasons I feel this
bill is is unnecessary it has problems
seeing none the oh
sorry representative Gilman thank you
madam chair um I agree with what you've
said and I just want to recognize that
um some counties are doing this they're
collaborating on traffic studies and um
uh what are the other
ones traffic studies and planning and
land use and and working with the
communities that lie within their Comm
lie within their region um to answer
those questions regionally so not each
one town is not uh coming up with a
solution that conflicts with the next
town so you what you said about the
Commissioners all getting together to um
talk about these things is what should
be happening and is not happening in
this
discussion seeing none the motion before
us is inexpedient to legislate on House
Bill 471
if you are in favor of the motion you
will vote Yes if you are opposed to the
motion you will vote no the clerk will
call the
role Vice chairman
McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk votes yes representative
France
yes representative karinski
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Walker yes representative
stavis
yes representative Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerana
yes representative Gerard yes
representative grund
yes the motion passes with a vote of 18
to Z the committee recommendation on
House Bill
471 is inexpedient to
legislate without objection the
recommendation will go on to the house
consent calendar and the report will be
you and with that the chair closes the
the chair now opens the executive
session on House Bill 373 local relative
to the management and regulation of town
real
property do I have a a motion
representative Murphy is recognized for
a motion thank you madam chair I'd like
225-8331
year
lease further comments
representative Colby thank you madam
chair
um in testimony we received 12
examples um printed out uh 10 of them
were Revenue generating
leases with more than half of them
potentially generating Millions over the
course of their
agreements municipalities and school
districts are currently desperate to
overcome increasing cost of providing
services
it is irresponsible to present
legislation that would handcuff efforts
uh to decrease property tax burdens in
anyway a simple majority in this case
should be a majority uh we should not be
advocating for further restrictions when
it comes to initiatives that generate
revenue or otherwise reduce the
operating costs and allowing
municipalities uh the ability to lower
our property taxes
further comments representative
grund thank you madam chairwoman um
so representative Colby pretty much said
what I was going to say but you know
when towns and school districts are
looking for Revenue sources we shouldn't
necessarily make it more difficult are
there a few examples in here that
probably you're cutting it close yes um
but you know it's what's presented to
the voters to vote and their voters
spoke at the time so um we need to not
make it harder to reduce taxes at this
time and I want to thank representative
kby for everything she added thank you
further
comments so I I have a few comments
um this amendment is um comes forward
today because during the the bill
hearing I listened to the feedback from
the committee so in the spirit of um
listening and compromise
I um present this amendment to you today
on this
um with regards to
fifths for entering into a lease of
greater than five years I felt that that
was important
because of the length of the
term I feel that it's when when you're
committing unused um Municipal property
for that length of of time
that there should be
a a higher majority than just the simple
majority so that's that's the reason for
that
further
comments representative
stavis thank you madam chair and I and I
do want to thank you for listening to
the comments and putting forward an
amendment in an attempt to to reach a
compromised position but I will never
compromise on what constitutes the will
of the voters and what constitutes the
will of of the voters is a simple
majority we have very very stringent
rules and regulations about when we must
have a two-thirds majority in this house
and we ought not to be imposing what we
believe to be reasonable
numbers percentages of majorities on
voters who who elect public officials to
do that it's just it's it's an
unwarranted intrusion of state power
into local
control representative
grundt thank you madam chair and U maybe
a clarification but is there any is this
bill retroactive or current leases that
are in
in my understanding is that no it's not
okay
I think
that's representative majori thank you
madam chairwoman um I'm going to argue
at a different a little bit of a
different side here if we're going to
require this kind of action so that
there is the greatest amount of input
from the legislative body I'm actually
opposed to this because it says may and
not shall now I don't support the bill I
don't support the amendment but if
you're going to have it drop the hammer
and say if you're going to do this for
more than 5 years you must go to the
legislative body and you must get
approval from them if you say may well
I'm not on the select board anymore
after tomorrow but um I would just say
no thanks I may some towns and we hear
about towns that may not be may may not
be as above board as other towns we've
heard that today they might just say no
we're not going to do it I find that
remarkable but it says May so I just
you if you if you continue to read the
the
the the intent of the amendment was that
um and I would further further say that
if a project is is a good idea and it's
bringing in
in Revenue through through through the
lease then there should be no issue with
with getting the Three-Fifths majority
um for the sake of it's it's beneficial
so I'm not concerned with that the piece
that I'm concerned with is the the
property that's being leased the fact
that it could potentially be
um committed for a long period of time
so therefore I feel that a simple
majority is is not the appropriate vote
threshold to um
approve such a matter further questions
or I didn't mean questions comments or
discussion representative majority thank
you and and um so so in line 14 at the
least more than 5 years then the
legislative body may vote well yeah I
assume that they they will vote but this
doesn't say that the select board or the
governing body shall put a warrant
article on for them to vote and that's
my concern that the language is
ambiguous such that we're you're going
to have to go to council and say does
this mean I have to put the b a ballot
measure on or I don't have to put a
ballot measure on I know exactly where
you want to go and what you want to do
and and quite frankly I'm I I think that
if you're going to bind future select
boards that you should have to have a
vote I just think that this language
leaves it open that it may not
accomplish what you're looking to
you
e
caucus um yes I will allow a caucus for
how long 10 minutes
okay so we will come back at quarter
past I can't see my watch is it one no
okay
e
the amendment to
20258 36h to House Bill 373 local are
comments seeing none the motion for us
2025-the
Amendment you will vote Yes if you're
are opposed to the amendment then you
will vote no the clerk will call the
role Vice chairman
McDonald
yes representative
Guthrie yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk votes yes representative
France
yes representative Kosinski
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Walker
yes Representative stavis
no representative Gilman
no Representative majori
no representative frock no
representative Colby
no Representative
gerna
no representative Gerard
yes amendment
2025-the
of 10 to8 is there a further motion on
the
bill representative
kazinski yes Madam chair I'd like to
make a motion to pass with the amendment
is there a second Madam chair I'll
second that motion representative Murphy
second the motion would you like to
kazinski okay any further comments
representative majority thank you madam
chairwoman um
I I think the original bill unamended
got to the point it says the town
meeting shall buy a vote um and it gave
it gave clear Direction what you must do
I think this bill with the amendment
just became much weaker and is going to
open up for legal uh issues in towns
which is only going to drive up costs
for towns so I'm opposed to the Bill
thank you further comments
representative Colby thank you madam
chair I Echo um Mr maor's uh
representative uh comments and I'm also
concerned about um representative gr's
comments uh in that there is no
you further
comments seeing none the motion before
us is ought to pass with amendment to
House Bill 373 local if you are in favor
of the motion you will vote Yes if you
are opposed to the motion you will vote
no the clerk will call the
role Vice chairman McDonald yes
representative
Guthrie yes representative Dolan yes
representative Elward
yes the clerk votes yes representative
France yes representative kazinski yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Walker yes Representative stavis
no representative
Gilman
no Representative majori
no representative Colby
no Representative gerana
no representative Gerard
no representative grunt no
yes the motion passes with a vote of 10
to8 the committee recommendation on
House Bill
373 local is ought to pass with
Amendment and that will go on the
regular calendar and the committee
report will be written
myself yeah I'm writing a note and The
Minority Report will be written by
representative
grund thank you and with that the
executive session on House Bill 373
at this time the chair opens the
executive session on House Bill 413
relative to subdivision regulations on
the completion of improvements and the
regulation of building
permits Madam chair refere Vice chairman
McDonald is recognized thank you I'd
like to uh make a motion of ought to
pass on HB 413 is there a second
representative Murphy is recognized
Madame chair I like to second
that representative McDonald would you
like to speak to your motion yeah I'll
just take a minute to refresh everyone's
memory uh what this does it extends
existing 5year exemption for subdivision
plans to seven year 7 years and
increases preliminary step from 2 years
to 3
years and that's all I have thank you
further comments representative Walker
is recognized yeah I believe this came
out of the housing committee
for uh to help improve the situation so
it's a very good thing further comments
representative
major I'm opposed to this bill for
several reasons but the one that sticks
out the most on page two lines 13 and 14
you've made a retroactive law and those
part our constitution should be
you representative
stavis thank you madam chair I also
oppose to this bill because because it
further erodes local control something
that we've seen a lot of today in this
executive
session um in my community in Lebanon
there is a development that has been
halted for 15 years
15 um they have asked for extension
after extension the last one we refused
they went to court they
won um that they are now going to be
putting up
buildings that were planned and approved
15 years ago should this law pass any
kind of code updates that have happened
in those subsequent years will be
non-consequential which I think is a
threat to life safety and that is one of
the reasons one of the many reasons I
oppose this
bill further comments representative
grund thank you madam chairwoman there
was another piece that um had been
brought forward during testimony that
made me think and wonder um would this
because it makes things retroactive if
there's any legal cases that were closed
could this potentially open them up as
well and I think that was a that's a
serious
concern other comments representative
majority thank you madam chair I want to
apologize to you um I said when I made
my comment that you did this that's not
fair I didn't mean you specifically I
meant the the general and I apologize to
you and the rest of the committee that I
did not want to assign that I'm sorry
thank you representative majority I
missed that comment I did not even hear
that now I
[Laughter]
comments seeing none the motion before
us is ought to pass on House Bill 413 if
you are in favor of the motion you will
vote Yes if you are opposed to the
motion you will vote no the clerk will
call the
role Vice chairman
McDonald yes representative Guth
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward yes the clerk
votes yes representative France
yes representative kazinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes Representative stavis
no representative Gilman
no Representative majori
no representative frock
no representative Colby
yes representative Gerard
no representative grunt
the motion passes with a vote of 11 to7
the committee recommendation on House
Bill 4 13 is ought to
pass and the majority report will be
written by I'll do that thank you Vice
chairman McDonald in The Minority
Report will be written by representative
and that will be on the regular calendar
if I didn't say that and with that the
executive session on House Bill 413 is
at this time the chair will open the
executive session on House Bill 229
local repealing the alternative
procedure for the adoption of zoning
ordinances do I have a
motion representative stavis is
recognized for a
motion thank you madam chair I like to
move itl on HB 229 on account of the
fact that the sponsor have never
bothered to show
up and also it's a bad Bill thank you I
will second that motion um
representative Colby seconds that and it
appears as though perhaps representative
stavis has already spoken to a motion
would you like to add any further
discussion no okay see see none the
motion before us is inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 229 local if you
are in favor of that motion then you
will vote Yes if you are opposed to the
motion you will vote no the clerk will
call the
role Vice chairman McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward yes
clerk votes yes representative France
yes representative kazinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative stavis
yes representative Gilman
yes representative
majori
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerana
yes representative Gerard
yes the motion passes with a vote of 18
to Zer the committee recommendation on
House Bill 229 local is inexpedient to
legislate and without objection the
recommendation Will Go On on to the
house consent calendar and the committee
report will be written by representative
stavis thank you and with that the
executive session on House Bill 229
next the chair will open the executive
session on House Bill 372 local relative
to lease agreements of equipment for
building or facility
improvements do I have a
motion I have a motion Madam chairman
thank you the chair recognizes Vice
chairman
McDonald I recommend uh OTP ought to
pass is there a
second representative kazinski is
recognized Madam chair thank you I'd
like to second that representative
kazinski seconds that motion
representative McDonald would you like
to speak to your
motion I will
pass is there any comments
discussion representative Colby is
recognized thank you madam chair I'm
still unclear as to
the point of the legislation is trying
to make um I see towns and school
districts utilizing multiple Financial
tools to keep buildings and fixtures in
working order um simply claiming misuse
of the statute is a matter of opinion
leasing allows for municipalities to
maintain Bond ratings for larger
projects and at the same old time uh
keep up with the cost of
Maintenance also to note is all the
lease agreements that were presented uh
we were presented with as evidence went
through a proper process uh through a
democratic
process um and none of the leases
circumvented that de Democratic process
the majority of Voters in their
respective communities voted in favor of
the projects a small portion of the
electorate is obviously disenchanted
with their neighbors decisions and I
don't believe this committee should be
supporting legislation that is created
because of a personal grievance
further comments representative grund so
basically representative kobby said
everything I want to do I was going to
say so I support her comments thank
you further comments discussion
representative Davis thank you madam
chair I would also just like to
reiterate the fact that we discussed at
our hearing that this is the redraft of
a bill that was uh sent to the
governor's desk in the last session and
it was vetoed by the Republican Governor
business
representative majori is recognized
thank you mad chairwoman and we also
have testimony um from well we also have
testimony which said that if we had if
the bill just had a a simple part about
except for energy performance contracts
that maybe we could have held our nose
and swallowed hard and agreed with this
but that was still left out um as as a
bill okay representative grund I was
just thinking that's okay um the one
thing I wanted to point out also it was
stated during testimony that the state
um I would like to um say that
indeed this bill passed the house this
is a refiling the exact
language of a bill that passed the house
last legislative session on consent
calendar out of this
committee it also obviously pass the
Senate and went to the governor's desk
and yes the governor did veto it and I
believe that it was vetoed because the
governor did not understand the
bill so a couple of other comments is um
very clearly that this statute lease
agreements of equipment with Escape
Clauses is indeed being used
improperly and it is incumbent upon the
legislature that when the legislative
intent
of a bill that became law is being
improperly used that it's incumbent upon
the legislature to address that through
legislation and that's exactly what the
bill that got vetoed did and that's
exactly what the bill before us
does the this bill prevents lease
agreements of equipment that becomes
fixtures
337e
because if equipment becomes a fixture
it it's a
fixture it cannot be returned and it
clearly the
list of in instances where this
particular RSA is being improperly used
it was was provided during the
hearing furthermore to be clear this
bill before us does not in any way Pro
prohibit
leases from from
being done
including energy performance contracts
19 I have asked
repeatedly since the day that the
governor vetoed the bill last
legislative
session um with regards to the the piece
about the energy performance Contracting
like it's not clear to me why that was
put in by the Senate I I've furthermore
I've asked and even the recent P after
the hearing what is the purpose of that
because those types of contracts can
still be done even if this bill becomes
law and I have yet to have an answer
that's why that Clause is not in the
bill I don't understand it it it
Exempted energy performance contracts
from from the the bill for period of 3
years well what happens after 3 years I
if I could get an answer and I you know
consideration and with regards to
personal grievances I'm not sure what
what that meant um
clearly clearly there's numerous
examples covering many years across the
state um and for those reasons I I I
support the the motion of ought to
comments seeing none the motion before
us is ought to pass on House Bill 372
local if you are in favor of the motion
then you will vote Yes if you are
opposed to the motion then you will vote
no the clerk will call the
role Vice chair McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan yes
representative Elward
yes clerk votes yes representative
France
yes representative kazinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes Representative stavis
no representative Gilman
no Representative majori no
representative frock
no representative Colby
no Representative gerana
no representative Gerard
no Representative grundt
yes the motion passes with a vote of 10
to8 the committee recommendation on
House Bill 372 local is ought to pass
that will go onto the regular
calendar and I will write the majority
report and The Minority Report will be
authored
you and with that the chair closes the
executive session on House Bill 372
local
at this time the chair will open the
executive session on House Bill 432
oh do representative Dolan is recognized
thank you madam chair I have a motion
um on House Bill 432 that it's
inexpedient to legisl is is there a
second representative Walker seconds the
motion would you like to speak to your
motion representative Dolan yes thank
you uh I
have four elements basically of my uh
objection to this
legislation uh first let me say that I
think it's without goes without saying
that that uh there
is a tremendous amount of empathy for
those people who are find themselves in
this
situation uh and that need either help
with alcohol problems or drug problems
or other related problems and I think
that that uh most of us can say that we
want to reach out and help them however
uh this bill for Falls far short on a
number of issues the probably the most
important is
safety uh this bill exempts the the
safety
requirements that we would normally
think would would happen especially in a
in a uh a recovery situation where
people are are
compromised
um we've Exempted the the uh the fire
alarm
requirements um there aren't any Ada
requirements that would
apply for use of
toilets uh opening and closing
doors certification of of a recovery
house is only required after it's been
open and in use for a
year uh and and not
beforehand secondly the public process
associated with with the recovery house
uh around local control which we've
we've heard a lot today about how
important that is to maintain local
control but we've Stripped Away the
requirement uh for a planning board or
or a zoning board to oversee uh these
requirements in other words uh the local
residents local community is really
going to have very little of any say as
to the sighting and and and
implementation of a recovery house there
will'll be no site plan review um
the community's input on things like
parking and so forth are eliminated in
this process in this
legislation thirdly uh volume it was
explained uh to us we we did have a u
the chair did uh appoint a subcommittee
to look into this matter and we met for
for a few hours uh and took testimony
and it looks like the uh the quantity of
recovery houses from The Advocates of
this uh situation are estimating that we
uh increase the quantity in the state
from currently about
1,300 to
15,000 and that's going to be uh that's
going to be uh apply to us to bring that
message back to our local communities
that that uh hey guys we're about to
increase recovery houses to 15,000 in
the state over a factor of 10 and uh is
that are those local communities ready
for that and willing to accept that and
the implications of of what that really
means and lastly uh although you can't
really consider consider this input and
as part of the vote to move forward or
not with this but this bill as flawed as
it is is mostly corrected by the by the
contents of a of a sister bill and it's
currently matriculating through the
Senate uh that I haven't seen and I
can't recommend to you that it's better
than or fixes everything but it's it's
certainly to me is an alternative a much
better alternative potentially than what
we have in front of us which I think is
terribly flawed and and sacrifices the
safety and well-being of those
desperately needy people that would be
using these recovery houses thank you
madam chair further comments
representative gerana thank you madam
chair um yeah I served on that
subcommittee as well just to touch on
one of those points um that the other
representative brought up um for that
number 1300 to 15,000 we're not talking
about recovery homes we're talking about
beds that are available right um I
agree and that's something that we can
all see in our own districts that our
constituents are calling for and we need
more beds in our communities and as we I
agree that this is not a perfect bill
which is where I would move that we
defeat the itl and move then move to
retain afterwards um because there are
some problems that with this bill that I
believe can be fixed through Amendment
um and in the meantime while we keep
working on ways to find solutions to
both this bill and maybe maybe other
bills brought up in the future how many
people are left on the streets for years
while we while we wait for maybe a minor
detail that we don't agree with that
could be amended if we just made went
back to retain and figured it out there
this is something that could help found
thousands of graned Staters over the
years and while we just slow this down
by saying we might need ADA requirements
or by throwing some other issues on
there that could be either fixed through
Amendment or as a homeowner it's your
job to figure out issues when you have a
home that doesn't have the right septic
or parking that's a homeowner issue
um
and it's just a shame that we slow down
the process of so many people having a
second chance while they're on the
streets um they could be either just not
sober in the first place or having
trouble with that process without these
homes being available in large parts of
our state including I know there's two
counties in New Hampshire one of which
is Coos and I'm I'm forgetting the other
one off the top of my head which have no
currently open um recovery
houses so there's just there's a large
need that this body needs to really take
seriously in figuring out how we address
our housing crisis the homelessness
crisis as well as the drug epidemic that
we're seeing here in New Hampshire and
this bill takes a serious stab at that
um so I think at the very least we
should defeat the itl and move to retain
thank you further comments
representative stavis is
recognized thank you madam chair I agree
with the com comments that
representative Shana just made I also
agree with some of the comments that
representative Dolan made this is far
from a perfect bill but better is often
the enemy of good and I can't think of a
better case than this in which better is
the enemy of good there are fixes we can
make to this bill real pretty simple
fixes if we just didn't itl it and move
to retain it and make those fixes and we
could we could meet the needs of some of
the people in our communities who
desperately need these places to
live F further
Walker all day we've been hearing about
local
control local control control each one
of our bills that we wanted to pass
local control here's one where it cuts
out local control shoehorns these things
in neighborhoods that might not fit
right might be septic issues might be
parking issues might be safety issues
God forbid I wouldn't want this that one
of these places burns up CU someone let
a match and the whole place burns up and
we kill 15 people because we got too
many people in the building but uh this
bill is highly flawed and highly
dangerous as is is and I look forward to
the Senate Bill coming through I want to
see what that does because this is a
need I recognize that it's a need but it
needs a lot more work than it
is further
comments representative
ger thank you yeah I just wanted to
bring back to the um that safety point
one more time um with the safety
requirements the only exemption that
these houses are given is that they
don't need a sprinkler in in every room
is effectively what it is um it has to
do with the sprinklers that's that's the
only the only ex exemption they get in
that
case representative Colby is recognized
thank you madam chair I think uh to
speak to representative Walker's
concerns is the goal here is to um
address concerns with local control at
least that's what I would like to see
come out of of um the ability to retain
the bill and work on it further um so to
your point and to the point we have been
making all day is yes uh local control
bill further comments represented
roock thank you madam chair um I too was
on the
subcommittee
and I had voted um with the motion of
the subcommittee committee to recommend
itl however after further reflection it
appears to me that the best way
of um moving this very important bill
forward would be to retain it in
committee and proceed to come out with a
good workable bill that protects the
rights and
responsibilities of
landlords of operat ERS of the recovery
homes and also
allows for the abing property owners and
the town's people in general to have a
say in the process so I would vote
for um retaining this bill in committee
working on it and coming up with a
really good bill
further
comments representative
McDonald thank you madam chair I also
was on the committee and Serv the chair
and one of the concerns I also share
with uh my friend and colleague uh
representative Walker is local control
uh all day we've heard from my other
colleagues and friends the end of the
table about local
control and I I got some really good
quotes that I'm taking down because
they're really good in case I can use
them sometime and not extending the long
arm of government into how
municipalities execute their Affairs
what's this bill do takes us long I'm in
government and and infects the
municipalities subvert to
locally elected officials can do their
jobs legislative deferring to local
control and unfortunately I wish I had
represent represent major speech because
it was excellent and I think a lot of it
there was in his that I want to say is
contained in that again
all day we've heard local control local
control local control on many many other
bills this bill no it is it's taken away
local control the way it's written and
you further comments I see
representative grund has a
comment thank you madam chair and i'
just like to repeat what said before is
that one of the things that probably
does need looked Act is part of the
piece of the part of the sorry the piece
is about local control so no one's
saying that
we are against it in this bill we're
saying we want to look at the bill and
its entirety and at the pieces and try
and fix the parts that are flawed
because overall this bill addresses a
strong need in our
state further
comments representative
FR thank you madam chair um a process
question if you
will um right now the motion before us
is itl
and we are expressing a desire
to uh to retain the bill in committee to
in order to work on it and come out with
a better
Bill U my understanding is that if itl
passes it just
ends um and if that is the case I would
request that the representative that
made the motion
withdraw the motion so that a different
motion I.E a motion to retain can be
introduced and we can do something that
actually benefits the people that are so
in need of recovery housing while
maintaining local control and local
further
comments we we need to ex deal with this
motion who is the who made the motion I
did so I guess the the fair question
would be are you interested in
withdrawing this motion yes or no no the
the the the
the you said no right the representative
that made the motion is not interested
in withdrawing ing therefore we need to
take a vote on this motion if this
motion does not pass then another motion
comments seeing none the motion before
us is in expedient to legislate on House
Bill 432 if you are in favor of the
motion you will vote Yes if you are
opposed to the motion you will vote no
clerk will call the role
chair Vice chairman McDonald
yes representative Guthrie yes
representative Dolan yes representative
Elward
yes clerk
vess representative France
yes representative Kosinski yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Walker
yes Representative stavis no
representative Gilman
no Representative majori
no representative frock
no representative Colby
no Representative gerana no
yes Representative grundt
the motion passes with a vote of 11 to7
the committee recommendation on House
Bill 432 is inexpedient to legislate and
calendar and representative Dolan will
write the majority report and The
Minority Report will be written by
thank you and with that the executive
closed
at this time the committee will resume
the executive session on House Bill 124
enabling a city or town Forest committee
to offer Surplus money to the town for a
deposit in the city or town general fund
well so we're resuming that that was
okay so I guess at this point in time I
I make a motion to accept the amendment
to
hb24 the amendment number 2025 d08
61h representative Dolan seconds that
representative fron would you like to
motion well I like the um the the new
amendment that you you presented it did
change um some wording in it and I also
just like the fact that it said that um
the fees may be offered after a majority
vote to do so it just clears a lot of
things up it keeps it in the unreserved
fund balance which I think is a good
idea as opposed to the general
representative
stavis thank you madam chair i' just
like to commend the prime sponsor for
being um amendable to making this change
at the last
moment further
comments representative
Colby thank you madam chair yes um much
gratitude to the prime sponsor uh and uh
for sticking with us uh today and uh
being dedicated uh to to your bill thank
you further comments representative
majori is recognized and to Echo the
same comments and also um commend the
prime sponsor and the co-sponsors for
working hard to find the kind of
property tax relief or or potential
relief for their Community um that
should set a standard for for uh that
should set a great standard for the
state so very commendable thank you
further comments
representative Colby is recognized thank
you madam chair and also for your
respect of local
control further discussion
comments I have a comment I I I too
would like to both commend and thank the
prime sponsor of this legislation for
being here all
day through
lunch and um it's a testament to his
hard work and his dedication and his
willingness to um participate in the
legislative process and I would also
like to thank OSS and the drafting
attorneys for responding to this um I I
would say unique request at such you
know without notice and to turn this
around so definitely
um a team effort and I would also like
the committee a member as as well for
for um I guess their cooperation and um
navigating this this novel situation I
think for the for this committee I I do
appreciate the collaboration in order to
come up with a solution that we didn't
expect um during executive U session and
to to work everybody together to arrive
where we're at so I'm I'm very pleased
with with everyone and and situation
further comments representative Dolan
thank you madam chair also uh kudos to
the the the chairwoman for being able to
uh have the flexibility to see through
this situation we had and and and work
with the sponsor to get us a a workable
Amendment uh thank you representative
comments okay s seeing none the motion
2025-the
Amendment you will vote Yes if you
opposed to accepting the amendment then
role Vice chairman
McDonald yes representative Guthrie yes
representative Dolan
yes representative Albert yes clerk
votes yes representative France
yes representative kazinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker yes
representative stavis
yes representative Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frog
yes representative Colby
yes representative ger
yes representative Gerard
yes representative grunt yes madame
chair
yes Amendment
2025 d-08 61h to House Bill 124 is
accepted by a vote of 18 to zero is
there a further
motion representative stavis is
recognized for a motion thank you madam
chair I would like to move a to pass
with Amendment on
hb24 is there a second I will second
representative Colby seconds the motion
representative stavis would you like to
speak to your
motion uh just to repeat uh what many
people have said before that I think
that this is a a very good measure uh
that has now been very carefully crafted
in consultation with lots of different
stakeholders and I um am happy to
support
comments
seeing seeing none the motion before us
is ought to pass
with Amendment on House Bill 124 if you
are in favor of the motion you will vote
Yes if you are opposed to the motion you
will vote no the clerk will call the
role Vice chairman
McDonald yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk votes yes representative
France yes
representative kazinski yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Walker yes representative stavis
yes representative
Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative fro
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerna
yes repres representative Gerard
yes representative grund
yes the motion passes with a vote of 18
to zero the committee recommendation on
House Bill 124 is ought to pass with
Amendment the without objection the
committee recommendation will go on to
the house consent calendar and the
Madam
chair I'll write it if
you who who made the motion
representative
stavis
okay so representative Murphy are you
you and with that the executive session
so that concludes our publicly noticed
business for today and our favorite part
of the day is afternoon
announcements so um a house session has
been been scheduled for Thursday March
13th and the committee will be pleased
to know that we have completed our
committee work on a total of um 61
hearings 60 house bills in one non-
gerine amendment that had been referred
to this
committee um so after crossover we will
take up our work on Senate bills that
have been referred to that will be
referred to this committee and I hope
that we have less Senate bills than we
had house
bills oh you you
looked
oh okay
okay so um with regards to committee
reports generally speaking that they're
due to the committee assistant by by
noon on Wednesdays so again that's less
than the 48 hours but it would be very
nice to be able to to to have those
um Pro
like submitted to me so that I can do
what I need to do so that I could pass
them um on to the committee assistant so
that they can do their um input into the
system and that they finally make their
way to the house Clerk and the
speaker and um any questions we have any
questions no okay no questions we're
good no um according to to my um
recordkeeping we're done unless
something bizarre comes up um that I'm
not aware of but um we've completed uh
We've um completed the bills that were
referred to this
Davis may I make a generic
statement only if it's
[Laughter]
good so I've I've been on this committee
since
2018 and the thing that I love about
Municipal and County government is that
despite our differences which at times
are
considerable when we disagree we do it
in a civil manner we don't attack one
another we don't vilify one another and
um frequently we are able to arrive at
really good compromises that make bills
better most of the time that's what
happened it didn't happen today so much
but that is going to happen every once
in a while we are going to have days on
which we largely disagree on things and
our executive session in the last time I
think we agreed on pretty much
everything so once again it is my
privilege to say how proud I am to serve
on this committee which I consider to be
the best Committee in the house uh and
to work with all of my colleagues in
better thank you representative Davis I
appreciate that and I um would also like
to say that I do appreciate every single
member of this
committee we have um we had a very
aggressive schedule and everybody um you
know showed up and participated in both
the hearings and the executive sessions
and I'm sure the the individual
caucuses and this is my fifth year my
third term and
um this this um
this this year thus far has been um very
interesting it's nothing like I've
experienced before um either obviously
sitting here because this is my first um
time being the chair and even sitting
sitting over here so I again I would
like to thank you as I I have before for
um your patience and your um commitment
to this committee and your hard work and
your um everything that you do to work
on behalf of the citizens of the granite
state and um I I look forward to
continuing to to work with with
everybody um after crossover so with
that
adjourned
e